i gotta ask because you grew up in
france yeah and
moving you you know about you know how
much well
you were telling us earlier about how
much more you can get paid doing the
same job
being in france and also having let's
say
less work hours as well what made you
decide
to give that up and move to japan
and have like a yeah because when i
uh tell my my story of my internship
to my friends can you do you really want
to go to japan
because i mean i don't want i want to i
want to have a life
and i could completely understand you
know yeah there is no
this is the the right way
you have a everybody has his way of
doing it and in my case
i wanted to work in japanese animation
industry
because i i like animation i like manga
and yes there is something how can
indeed
a bit sorry majorities
but yeah but
yeah it's the way to learn also
yes it's kind of a bit i think this is
just particularly passionate
yeah it just sounds like you you are
doing it purely for the past i was gonna
say for that pay you better be
passionate
so but uh yes but i mean animation the
two three years are hard so if you want
to do a career
in japan so you have to speak japanese
yes
you you can manage to to work in japan
with english but just a some few studios
will open the doors because they have a
translator
or not and but if you can speak japanese
more open doors will offer too yeah and
as we've established
like you know from your stories is that
you know getting to know the people as
well it just takes you so far
it really does seem that like if you do
speak japanese it's like way easier to
get into the anime industry than i think
people
make it out to be yeah it's definitely
an easy mode isn't it yeah
i mean it's it's the same moving to any
country and trying to join in their
industry right
i i think because you almost find it
people put like the anime industry on
like a pedestal
right yeah like it's the anime industry
it's mythical it's japanese we don't
know what happens
right but when you talk to people it's
like oh yeah i get paid like two euros a
frame
that's going back to the the the story
of the guy who you know
came up and said like that he wanted to
work a trigger yeah yeah guarantee he
has
no idea no idea what it's like to
actually working through it's like it's
like six o'clock
he's like ready to go home and
everyone's like no no it's four more
hours yeah
yeah because yes in japan you have a
jungle
and uh you so you just you say oh you
can
leave the studio at eight but nobody
live at eight
exactly exactly you can leave it and
then you see nobody leaves
leaving a yeah the clock out times in
japanese companies is not an official
clock
yeah it's like a suggested yeah but yeah
so so when i was uh working at
graffinica
and first i in my mind i say one year
we see how one year will be if
it's too hard i will go back to france
and
yeah first faster one year and
okay i think i can do one yen plus one
like that
one yeah when you have one yeah and now
it's i'm at my five years
and yes i still i yeah and now i have
found a good schedule for c
and i learn a lot of from my same pies
and yeah
i can do more do more yeah
how much longer do you think though
because you you're you said you're 31
right yeah still doing all-nighters
uh yeah crunch time
i was gonna say because like i've just
hit my 30s as well and
man all nighters they they are def they
definitely hit different yeah
your body in my 30s and i can't do all
nighters anymore because when you're
turned to you oh
when i was younger getting your drink at
night and you go
to work the other day yeah it was okay
now it's like oh it's 11 p.m [ __ ] i'm
trying i definitely do find that my
willpower is
over exerting my body i'm like no i can
do this yeah i'm dying
so yeah so you have to push yourself and
like i said
um so it's a lot of hours you are
sitting
yeah and sometimes i was i don't think
i feel well because i had a lot of pain
in my feet
because i was because i was always
sitting sitting and so they had an
amount of
water water blood or my ankles were
swollen oh my god so that's that's like
that's
that's what happens you know when you're
like sitting in a plane for a long time
right so
oh i guess it is good from that and so i
had to oh
good to get up and walk because it's
about 2.4